things should look dangerous while being
safe whether they were on land in the
air or at sea uncharted brings all the
magic to the screen how many safety rigs
were edited out which locations were
complete cg creations we've got all the
behind the scenes footage you are
looking for
number one
has he ever felt more alive the stunts
is something i've always really enjoyed
tom was radiating joy in this one the
whole setting wasn't real but it was
pretty darn close a practical ship was
built we had part wood and park green
ship moments to ensure a smooth editing
process ropes and masts were ready for
tom holland to get some cool action
shots on even though some of them were
green or supported by green only to get
the cg treatment in post as much work as
it was to put all these parts of the set
together in the end it was much easier
to film this exciting scene in a studio
instead of out on the unpredictable
water the water on set was real though
so tome was properly drenched
number two
that's gotta hurt tom holland didn't
know just how much of a powerhouse of a
co-star he'd be getting in tatty
gabrielle who had a martial arts
background before joining uncharted the
actress went all out used to her own
training rather than stage fighting and
only realizing the error of her ways
when it was a bit too late you don't
have to like
kick him
and i feel so bad holland didn't know
what hit him but it did help to amp up
his performance and fighting in the
scene while she was playing tough on
screen gabrielle was aware of what it
meant to hurt tom i was not trying to
beat up spider-man please those who love
spider-man don't hate me
number three the view from the top is
great tom was bringing his performance
in uncharted to new heights as he was
rigged up to a harness and climbing
masts like it was his job which
technically it was the actor deserves a
lot of credit because he really was
doing the work climbing and braving
these heights himself the harness and
wires hooked up to the actor were really
only there for safety instead of helping
him to actually carry out the stunts
number four
how many times could tom holland be hit
by a car in a day you're on take 12 and
like can we go again and you're like no
and that wasn't even the end of it 17
takes were needed altogether to get the
goods most of what we see in the movie
was actually fully blue from the walls
to the floor to the car itself which in
reality was a specially constructed
backend of a car including some pretty
solid car detailing it was much safer
and more comfortable to get hit with
this buggy repeatedly but it was still
far from being an enjoyable experience
so to do it myself was really exciting
but then i had to do it and i broke
myself number five
thank you for flying wahlberg airlines
the sully actor got to embody being a
pilot in the air behind the wheel of a
semi-practical aircraft the structure
they used looked and felt real but in a
way it was more like an immersive video
game no risk of high pressure air here
filming safely on the ground with
cameras at every turn and a blue screen
landscape ready to be replaced with
visual effects
number six
in a trunk in a car in a plane actually
filming the airplane sequence required
many different locations one of them
being inside the actual aircraft which
was actually just a decked out room in
the studio equipped with cameras on
dollies practical props galore and a
whole lot of rigging to make sure
holland could perform his stunts safely
number seven
this plane exit was a bit quick but
filming lasted a long time they shot
that sequence for five weeks even his
spidey acrobatics couldn't prepare him
for the experience of flying through the
air this wildly tom even called it the
hardest thing he's ever done on screen
tom holland was really testing his
limits rigged up in a special circular
rig that held him steady and then much
like machines used to prepare astronauts
to go into space they would spin him
around at varying levels the actor kept
wanting to push harder to simulate his
falling through the air and wound up a
bit nauseous by the end of it
but it pays off looking oh so real in
the final edit with all the blue and
safety rigging around him edited out
number eight
you better hold on tight tom was honest
about the fact that he was shooting
stunts that were far bigger than
anything he'd ever done before there
were days filming uncharted that holland
was portraying nathan drake a hundred
feet in the air safely hooked up to
harnesses but still clinging onto the
large crates for dear life the blue sky
he was surrounded by during filming was
a little less sky-like and a little more
blue screen but it did the trick
this definitely pushed him but with all
the safety equipment in place holland
managed to perform on set so the cg team
could perform easily while they did
their edits
number nine the action never stopped not
only was he trying to not fall off the
boxes tom was going full parkour mode
leaping through the air with the help of
a harness that allowed him to fly more
smoothly and of course safely each box
the actor was interacting with while
shooting the sequence was attached to a
specially made kooka arm these moved on
their own making the obstacle
unpredictable as could be for holland
tom wasn't feeling so brave facing the
dreaded kooka arms that would either
rock or spin him around as he moved
across them the actor wound up being
rigged to a kind of pulley system
laundry line that kept him safe and was
magically erased away in the editing
phase
number 10
let's hope you don't get seasick mark
wahlberg and tom holland didn't hold
back fighting together against skilled
stuntmen on a boat on set filming this
sequence was another case of a hybrid
set partially practical with blue screen
elements to make editing all the cg
details easy for the visual effects team
with blue screens on the horizon and
holland hooked up to a harness that
facilitated any leap jump or casual
backflip over his co-star the team was
set the final edit shows such seamless
cgi we never would have guessed there
was actually this much blue on the set
number 11.
acrobatics in a suit piece of cake just
because they were wearing formal wear
didn't mean they were keeping it classy
it was brutal the epic formal fight
looked nearly as dazzling on the day as
it did in the editing room the cg was
slick and subtle in this case the battle
was carried out looking just as cool as
it does in the movie only with some
wires to make sure tom was safe swinging
over the railings and flying through the
lights number 12.
land hoe unless you're already on land
and indeed they were one blue screen
ship coming right up a solid place to
carry out adventures tearing through
very real sails and feeling the power of
a ship the landscapes brought to life by
the vfx team bring a perfect sky and
water that makes us feel like we're
right on the ocean with them
number 13. anyone know how to pull off
this escape the actors were jumping into
fountains running through a roof of a
maze and all for real this setting was a
pretty amazing base and made the cgi
team's job very simple touching up some
bits here removing any equipment in
place for safety and we've got movie
magic make no mistake just the
coloration work done in post goes a long
way
number 14
in one of the less glamorous moments
slick and aesthetically cool in the
final cut while in reality this desk
toss was looking far lighter and
brighter while filming though some cg
was needed to clean up the image and
give it the moody blue vibe we get
holland really was getting thrown around
you know there's bangs and bruises here
and there but it's part of the job it's
easy to see where all those injuries he
got came from
number 15. which magical location will
they visit today whether they were
getting their feet wet taking to the
real water or going exploring caves
making the shots good enough for the
final edit was a team effort to bring
reality to the film the team worked to
bring real locations to the screen
allowing their vfx team to take care of
the details when needed adding some
lights and effects enhancing visuals to
perfect the final image
uncharted manages to bring the magic of
the game to the big screen with footage
that does justice to the original game
all while bringing a new story to life
the visuals take us around the world and
to locations we'd never likely see
otherwise making sure we really get to
experience the ride which scene would
you like to see in action on set